I was determined to be a designer.
A fashion designer.
My career was built
off my childhood happy place
of crafting with my mother,
and I dreamt of unleashing my creativity
in an industry that was borne
on style and trends and luxury.
It was a contradiction to my own childhood
of hand-me-downs and no logos,
often teased by my peers.
I grew up in the north
of England, off grid.
My parents worked as local food farmers,
and I had a real innate understanding
of where things came from.
We were the bottom of the food chain.
We all worked as farmers,
and I watched our small wind turbine
turn natural resources
into energy firsthand.
It did also mean if it wasn't windy,
I couldn't watch TV.
Getting into my dream industry.
I'm a very inquisitive person,
so I decided to pick away at the seams.
And so six years ago, as the
creative director of Mother of Pearl,
I embarked on a mission
to make a fully sustainable
collection for my brand.
I didn't really know what that meant,
so I journeyed from field
to finished product,
emotionally engaging
with the people and the planet,
picking away the chains,
linking them back together.
We all get the notion
of farm to table, right?
We understand where
our fresh produce comes from.
It's written on the packet
and also from point of harvest
to the final product,
it kind of looks the same.
But what about field to fashion?
Fashion is also born of natural resources.
Your clothes come
from either an worm, an animal,
agriculture, forestry or fossil fuels.
Without worms, there is no silk,
no sheep, there's no wool.
Without agriculture, there’s no cotton,
no trees, no viscose.
And polyester, which is the most
widely used fabric of all,
because it’s cheap,
comes from fossil fuels,
is made of crude oil,
which is the same oil
that you put into your car,
the same fuel you put into your car.
When we talk about climate change,
we talk about the big stuff.
We talk about aviation, travel,
shipping, logistics,
agriculture, industrialization,
plastic pollution, fossil fuels.
But this is where your clothes come from,
and they are playing their part.
Take a polyester dress, for instance.
It is both fossil fuel
and plastic pollution combined.
When it's made,
it contributes to climate change
in its industrial processing.
When it's washed, it releases
microplastics into the ocean,
into the food chain, into us.
When you throw it away,
it ends up in landfill,
and in landfill, it takes
hundreds of years to degrade.
It's no different
than your plastic packaging,
but it does give trashy dressing
a whole new meaning.
(Laughter)
Thank you.
OK, so how did we get here?
We buy three times as many clothes
as we did in 1980
and wear them for half as long.
Your grandmother
would have mended her clothes,
but now three out of five
end up in landfill
within the first year of purchase.
It changed within one generation,
and it's set to increase
by 62 percent by 2030.
This is one of the biggest landfills.
This is in Chile, and it can now
be seen from space.
It's mostly also made up
of unused and unsold clothing.
So mass industrialization
and a linear production model
of global capitalism
gave birth to the notion that we could
and should have it all faster and cheaper,
which means we've lost
connection to our clothes.
We do not know or seem to care
where they come from.
And when I say we,
I mean all of us that wear clothes,
but also the brands that make them.
When you look in your label
of your clothing,
it will tell you
where it was manufactured,
but it doesn't tell you how it was spun,
woven, dyed, finished.
Also, it doesn't tell you
about the 3.4 billion people
that work in the industry,
70 percent of which are female,
often invisible,
and for the most part
not paid a living wage.
In fashion, we love to talk
about equality, feminism,
diversity, empowerment.
We celebrate the celebrities
and the influencers that wear our designs,
and yet we don't talk
about the women that make them.
We treat them just like
that polyester dress,
disposable and cheap.
And in that search
for that cheap supply chain
and cheap materials,
your garments here,
one of your garments today,
that you're wearing,
could have traveled
through five different countries,
and up to 20 different
processes along the way.
Chances are your outfit
is better traveled than you are,
and your wardrobes most definitely are.
So,
we have to choose ethics, too.
But how do we do this?
Fashion is borne on buying more,
shopping more, consuming more.
When I was at design school,
they just taught me
to design something beautiful,
and how it was made
was almost an afterthought.
But now, with everything
that I've learned,
I flipped that entire process on its head.
So I start with sustainable,
traceable supply chains,
and I design from there up.
Some designers would suggest
that was hindering creativity,
but to quote the economist Kate Raworth,
"Boundaries unleash potential."
Look at what Mozart did
with a five-octave piano.
And I would agree.
So with everything I learned,
this is what I did for our brand.
I set my non-negotiables.
This is the best possible practices
of the supply chain.
For instance, we use natural organic
farming practices for our natural fibers
and replacement of synthetics
or virgin synthetics like polyester.
There's many more,
but they are just some of the solutions.
This was also designed for two reasons.
It was designed as a kind
of benchmark for my team.
So we had kind of goals to work to,
but it was also
to help educate the consumer.
Most online stores, when you shop,
you can filter them by size, color, fit.
But for us, we also let you filter it
by attribute or material,
trying to put ethics and aesthetics
in the same conversation.
But only once I’d implemented this --
and it took a long time to do it,
and we were very proud --
but what I also realized
is that we just made
a better version of an existing system
which was broken.
It's the best of,
but it's still take, make, use and lose.
And so now I realized we have to add
another link to that supply chain
and join it all together
and create a circular system.
And by that I mean so many things.
But for an example,
if we're going to cut a tree down
and we replace it,
could the replacement
add more value back to the forest?
What about if regenerative
and organic farming practices
could become the new normal,
and each picker’s lives nourished
along with the soil itself?
And then new links could be added
for every aspect of the business.
What if we looked
at profit and loss, for instance?
What if we turn that into pay it forward?
What if we reimagine
the concept of success?
They say we eat
a credit card's worth of plastic
every week with the microplastics.
And when all is said and done,
we won't be able to eat money.
For me, the answer is very simple.
The very notion
of questioning everything is key,
and being responsible for my actions
as a business leader
and an individual is key.
And for those that are willing
to not think and rethink,
we have to pass legislation.
On this journey,
I didn't think it was very revolutionary
trying to meet my sheep
that made my clothes,
but it turns out it was.
Before I knew it, I was on the news,
the subject of a documentary,
writing columns for British "Vogue."
And that gives me a lot of hope.
But fashion is still everything you think.
It's trends, fast pace, logos, brands.
But to fashion something
is to make something.
And that was where my passion came from.
And what I've learned in this journey
is if I'm going to continue to design
and fashion clothing,
I must also fashion our future.
The two things come hand in hand.
Yes, there are technical solutions
to this problem, to these problems,
and I can talk endlessly about them,
from biomimicry-based dyes and finishes
to regenerative and recycled textiles.
And it's important.
Technology is important.
But the other thing
I've learned in this journey
is that it's only when we reconnect
back to the living world
and look at it in awe and wonder
and the respect that it deserves
will true systemic change happen.
And when I talk about the living world,
I talk about the people and the planet.
Box-ticking is greenwashing,
and greenwashing is dangerous.
It's just the medicine to a symptom
and not the solution to a problem.
And fashion absolutely
should not cost the Earth.
Nature designs or fashions
the most incredible designs there are.
We just simply forgot to look.
So my ask:
next time you open your wardrobes,
instead of seeing clothes, brands, logos
and perhaps your favorite dress,
delve a little bit deeper.
Go to Narnia.
And instead see
the vast and unique ecosystem
that makes each piece individual
and its inherent connection to our planet
on which all of our lives depend.
Thank you.
(Applause)